[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers
my friends this is gunjan here welcome
to my 67th
episode of dirty chess tricks
in this episode i am going to show you a
wonderful high profile
tricky line against g6 elekine
from the white perspective
the critical position arises after the
following opening move order
e4 knight to f6 e5
knight to d5 d4
well now black challenged the white
center with d6
and accordingly as per the theory knight
to f3
is one of the best reply
well here it doesn't matter whether
black continue with first bishop to g4
or g6 let's say the most popular choice
is bishop to g4
and after bishop to e2 e6
or g6 are two favorable choices by the
black hand
in this episode we are going to look at
the move g6
however there's an important point i
like to highlight here that
many black players had made this blunder
namely d captures e5
where our first tricks comes into the
picture immediately
with knight capture c5 bishop captures
e2
queen captures e2 and now you can see
the danger
white is threatening queen to b5 jack
and
nabbing the b7 pawn which surprisingly
not easy to defend
probably the most popular choice here is
c6
stopping the threat but here comes the
sequence
which clearly gives white an upper hand
starting with queen to f3
attacking on f7 if f6 then queen to h5
and then there will be sacrifice on g6
so obviously the only response here is
knight to f6
after this i hope you indeed see the
deciding finish
yup queen to b3 double attack
and more or less black is going to lose
the game very quickly
after the following sequence e6
queen captures b7 knight to d7
and now simple move in the world knight
capture c6
clear healthy two-point advantage with
ongoing attack
so d captures e5 is a great disaster in
this position
and now the move which we are going to
concentrate for the rest of the video
is g6
well as for the database there are more
than 150 games
goes into this direction where i am
afraid just
one move and white can deliver a nasty
surprise
to the black camp
did you spot it yup this
golden moon knight to g5
creates such problems for the black game
and as we will see there are some nasty
tricks
are looming in this position
first thing first black has to take the
bishop because
if he goes back let's say bishop to f5
then after e6 black is in a huge trouble
he can't take with the pawn the simple
reason is
after g4 that poor bishop is
trapped so that is right out of the
equation
[Music]
and when black played this obvious move
bishop captures e6
our big idea is knight takes e6
pawn takes e6 and now bishop to g4
try to regaining our pawn back with a
huge
light square weaknesses around the black
king
chess engine already suggests that black
should forget about this pawn
and start developing some pieces however
we should also note that what happens if
black tries to hold on to this extra
pawn
let's say queen to d7 white continue his
assault
on the e pawn with queen to e2
and now the only way to defend this pawn
is to play king to f7
but just one move castle on the king
side
hell look at black's position for one
pawn
he has completely misplayed his pieces
and on top of everything rook to even is
coming in the mix
and sooner or later once that black pawn
is going to disappear from the board
black position crumbles very quickly
i have attached a sample line in the pgn
where a 2400 rated player crushed
a 2200 in just mere 34 moves
so obviously black has to take this
bishop
and after that once we recapture with
the queen
[Music]
you can already see how much danger
black is already facing just within
the seventh move of the game
not only white has some multiple threads
including
knight to f7 e6 and even
queen to b5 jack but to parry
all of them black has to find the only
accurate move
e6 which i don't think so
each of your opponent can find it
apart from e6 black can try other moves
as i have highlighted over here
but they are miserably fails for example
i have even seen the bishop to g7
big blunder and the refutation is yup
queen to f3 double attack
and black already get a losing position
in just mere eight moves
okay what about d captures e5
again this is a very bad move and the
response is very obvious
queen to f3 attacking on f7
if knight to f6 then we have d catches
e5
a very strong reply so that means
black has to move the f on and it
doesn't matter whether f6 or f5
white has this dazzling knight intrusion
knight to e6 attacking the queen queen
has to stay on the d
file and after anywhere she goes
let's say queen to d6 we have this
cute tactics and i hope you indeed
spotted
queen captures d5 bam
white is come out as a whole piece of
and the obvious tactical point is if
black foolishly take this queen then
after knight capture c7
king to f7 and knight captures d5
yes indeed white keep his extra peace
the third move i want to consider is
ethics
but again this is a bad idea by black
and many players has played it
the simple refutation is this lovely
night sacrifice
bam
okay black has no choice he has to take
it
and now we are going to hunt this king
down
with following sequence queen to f3
check
if black wants to keep his extra piece
then king to e6 is a force reply
after that we play this very simple move
c4 and believe me this knight
cannot move why what happens
if knight goes anywhere let's say b6
well then we have this forcing sequence
d5 shack king to d7
queen to g4 check queen to g6 jack
king to d7 queen to f5 jack
king to e8 and now the sting in the tail
e6
and that poor king is completely
boxed in last but very important tactic
is when black plays the only move queen
to c8
white has this wonderful resource
look at this b3
and in the next turn we are going to
play bishop to b2
and take the black rogue and even black
can see that one is coming
he cannot save it as any piece moves
then we can deliver the queen check and
nab it
so that is one of the force variation
which gives white
a clearly winning age just within the
opening stage
so you can see how tricky this position
is and accordingly
e6 is the only fitting reply
which saves all the threat
you might say hang on but isn't white
can deliver this
check well of course you can but the big
problem is
after knight to c6 queen captures b7
and the moon knight to b4 black has
multiple threats and it looks like
white has played this opening like a
beginner where
he has only two pieces out where black
has
multiple threads on the board so that is
why i am not going to recommend that
line
[Music]
and theory suggest here to play the move
c4
but i like the second big alternative
namely
queen to f3 setting up
yet another tricky platform for the
black camp
well it is very important to note here
that black cannot play queen to e7
in order to protect a pawn because
after c4 knight to b6 and
queen captures b7 white emerge
with a clear pawn advantage
so that means at this position the force
response is queen to d7
not only protecting the f7 but
if necessary then the knight of bishop
can reroute
to the e7 square
okay here white can play c4 and get
a good advantage but i am going to
introduce
my own novelty in this position which
haven't been played
in a single feed a game and you will be
surprised to see
how difficult to handle this very simple
night move
for the black cam once again
as i have shown here black has multiple
choices
but amazingly enough all of them gives
white
a healthy pawn advantage let's see
each by turn and find out how
white can get the upper hand
the first move i want to consider is
knight to b6
which is again fails due to the obvious
response
e catches d6 doesn't matter however
black respond
d captures e6 and now knight to e4
looking at gc4 on f6 square
black has to play bishop to g7 in order
to stop it
but then white deliver this deciding
blower
yup you got it knight captures d6
not only winning a pawn but the
important tactic is
after queen captures d6 queen to f7
king to d8 and now queen captures g7
asking black do you have enough for
today
the second move i want to consider is d
captures e5
and against this once again white has a
very simple sequence
knight captures d5 pawn captures d5
and now queen to f6 attacking the rook
rook to g8 and queen captures e5
jack the big point is
no matter whichever piece comes in
between
let's say bishop to e7 in the next move
we are going to take on h7 and again in
this position
white come up with a clear pawn
advantage
the third move i want to consider is how
about
eliminating this dangerous knight with
knight capture c3
but doing so has to give up the b7 pawn
and we are happy to grab it as
now black has to deal with the rook
threat
so accordingly queen to c6 is a forcing
reply
but after the following sequence queen
to see a check
misplacing the black king followed by
this check
which leads to the exchange of queen
and at the end when white recapture this
night
if you count the material not so
surprising
once again white emerged with a healthy
pawn up
and on top of everything here black get
this misplaced king
last but not least probably the most
critical response here is
h6 but after this once again the tactic
favors the white
we are going to chop the definite
and the threat is very obvious knight to
f6
so black has to take on d5 afterwards
yup the familiar tactics queen to f6
attacking the rogue rook to g8
and now the star moon e6
well black has no option he has to take
this pawn
and after that yup we are going to play
knight captures e6 which
keep the black king permanently in the
center
and another big point is when black
complete his
development let's say knight to c6
we have this very simple sequence
knight to f8 attacking the queen rook
captures f8
now queen captures g6 if rook to f7
then white has a multiple choice
including c3 or queen to g8
so the fourth response is queen to f7
and after queen trade white can simply
respond with c3
and this time around apart from healthy
point advantage
black has this double pawn and obviously
with some careful play it is only white
who is playing for the full point
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile tricky line against the
move g6
remember play the moon knight to g5
and after bishop takes and queen takes
in almost all the variation it is only
white
who is come up with a healthy pawn
advantage
which is very critical if you playing a
tournament game
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care